Okay.
Before I start the podcast,
I know this is weird cause I'm
not saying what's going on.
I just got to let you guys know. Um, I
got a big tour coming up this year and uh,
all the presales for most of
my shows are going on sale.
I'm a special password has been created
for podcast listeners to get tickets
first, use the code Billy
Baldwin, you get it.
Baldwin,
all capitals,
B I. L. L. Y. B. A. L. D. W. I. N. M.
It's active now midnight on
Sunday eastern standard time.
And uh, the public sale
will be Friday, March 9th,
12:00 PM all links will be
on bill [inaudible] dot com
soon I will be in Atlanta,
Georgia, San Francisco,
Dublin, Ireland, London,
England for my 50th birthday,
Minneapolis, Detroit, Portland, Oregon,
Seattle, Houston, Dallas,
Las Vegas, um, Maryland,
Virginia, Charleston, South
Carolina, Inglewood, California,
Denver, Boston, Baltimore, Atlantic
city, Chicago. More dates to come,
jump on the website and a, whatever
you use. The, what the fuck do you go?
I guess we're going to have links on
all this shit, right? That's right.
There'll be on the website. I'm
sorry. All right, so check that out.
My tour for a 2018 and once again,
thank you to everybody who's planning on
coming out to my shows. I appreciate it.
And now he is
podcast.
Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for
the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
I'm going to go with uh, what's today?
Thursday first, second, third, fourth,
fifth March 5th, March 6th. You're
asking the wrong person. I know.
I'm asking the wrong person.
I'm recording this on March 1st.
A very special guest on the podcast.
We've had two in a row,
two special guests in a row,
which means my podcast continues to get
more and more special as that dropped
the fucking recorder.
Uh,
we have the great Al Jourgensen
from ministry right here. Uh,
he's got a new album coming out and uh,
for whatever reason he wanted to come
on my stupid podcast to promote it.
One of the legends of
a really less 30 years.
Basically, you invented an entirely
new kind of music, right? You will,
you were credited with coming up with a,
what they call an industrial,
something like something like that.
I just think it was probably a
bad strain of acid in the 90s
well, you getting credit all the way back
into the 80s though, are you? Well, yeah,
that was the good strain of acid. The
nineties kind of went down hill. But uh,
what is, what is the golden
age of acid, would you say?
Oh, the 60s definitely when,
when they finally figured out the,
uh,
the DMT compounds that we're an organic
plants and we're able to make it
chemically that was the golden age because
it was pure and it before it hit the
streets and they cut it with strict
nine and baby aspirin and whatever else.
Right. They were cutting, I mean, I
lived with Timothy leary for two years.
How to here in Jesus Christ and
you survived, uh, not only that,
to survive,
I can't wait for the book to
come out because what would
do is he would just, uh,
have me inject like psychedelic compounds
that were sent to them by universities
around the world and then he'd
take notes on me as the Guinea pig.
As University's code for the CIA
or was it actual like university
while Alex Jones. Fuck it.
So wait, so how did it,
how her, well, how do you meet a
guy and how does he bring up, hey,
you want to live with me for a while
and while you don't have to pay rent,
I'm just going to occasionally
inject you with, uh,
some acid I got through the mail that's
allegedly from a university. Well,
the story of o wound up
with Tim is actually better
than me being with Tim as I
met Tim through William Burroughs,
uh, which was in Jesus Christ.
Story on how I met William Burroughs.
And we did a video.
We played wide receiver for the Houston
Oilers at, I was Ken Burns. Ken.
I know he's, he's one of the
beat writers that I never read.
Did he write naked lunch? Uh, yeah,
he wrote naked dead. Yes ma'am.
Um, amongst other things, uh,
Nova Express. Um, yeah, the,
the guy is a genius and we wound
up working with them because, uh,
basically because we sampled,
uh,
some of his spoken word and
a Warner brothers wouldn't
release our record at the
time was a psalm 69,
I believe them so early nineties,
and they wouldn't release
it. And they said, well, we
can't get clearance for this.
And so it was a little blurb and random
notes and rolling stone that said
ministry, I'll postponed for another
year until they can figure this out.
And then the boroughs, people
called me and said, nobody asked us,
we'd be happy to give you the shit
man. Oh Wow. You know, uh, hey,
when do you want to work?
You want to do some other stuff?
They were all happy about it.
So then I wound up hanging
out with bill and Kansas.
When did the album come out then?
So they didn't have to shelve it for you?
It's like shelf for about three months,
but it wasn't like the year that
there were saying and all this.
And then we got clearance and then,
uh,
William Bill Burroughs introduced me to
Timothy leary during that lollapalooza
toward, and then out to the
Lollapalooza tour was done. Uh,
I was kind of sick of rock music, so I
just wanted to take a year or two off,
um, because it was just, it was just
really gross. It was just, you know,
all the after parties and all this stuff.
It just, it just gets old after a while.
So it wasn't the music that was
happening at the time, it was just,
you were burned out from all the
partying and all that, everything.
So I moved in with the psychedelic master
of all time to get my head together,
which is not a good, I was
trying to picture how this, this,
this was going to work.
Like I was sick of the partying,
so I moved in with Timothy Leary so you
could experiment on me with like acid
and shit. All right. You know,
you know who owns the, uh,
the notes that he took a
on all of my trips. Uh,
because this was a weekly thing
so you can fucking tripping in.
This guy says looking at you taking notes
in the corner. I never, yeah, it was a,
it was dropped acid. Is that how you
could say oh no, no, no. I injected it.
Oh sorry. Like a fucking lab
rat. Okay. He, while Jack did,
cause he knew I was a junkie at the time.
I haven't done drugs in 15 years by
the way, except for psychedelics.
I haven't done heroin and coke and all
that crap. And why, why psychedelics?
Uh, it's a cheap and easy Uber way to, uh,
to get to what people would call
enlightenment as opposed to like doing it
through yoga and stretching meditation.
And that just takes too long.
This just cuts to the quick,
and you're right there where all the PD,
no,
that's why I don't like weed versus
alcohol. I feel like alcohol, you earn it,
you know, you got to get it down the
hatch. You make the face and like we,
especially the shit they got now,
it's like you'd take two or three tokes
and then you sit down and it's like
you're borderline trip. And I just don't
feel like I earned it. I feel like it,
I feel like a trust fund
kid while I say this. Uh,
I mean as far as like textiles in the
modern age or if this is cutting in and
out, this is my shitty thing. I, I can't
move too much. All right. Sorry. It,
it's one of the few things that,
uh,
have actually improved over these
recent years is the quality of pot and
obviously the quality of electronics,
thanks to like stolen alien technology
or whatever the fuck we got going. Right.
Um, yeah, the quality of Pod has
improved to the point to where, um,
it's almost like a,
you used to really get stoked for like
a weekend of mushrooms and now it's just
like you smoke pot every day and it's
just like the weekend a mushrooms just
like, it's Kinda the same thing. Yeah.
The pots improved, especially really here.
I've never taken mushrooms either.
I know that any of the hallucinate,
let's stuff this weekend. Well
you're going to Vancouver show. Yeah,
I'm going to go job with some showrooms.
You could go to the back then.
I don't know if I want to do
that. Uh, I, I think I basically,
I think it's just my headphones
and it keeps cutting in and out,
but I'm watching the little bubbles here
and they keep going up like I'm talking,
so we seem good. Yeah. Okay,
cool. Um, well you know what,
there's a lot of people out there like
myself that have never tried any of this
shit. So what, what is it like to be on,
on mushrooms? I'm never going to do it.
Maybe when I get like my kid grows
up and goes out of the house, you'll,
you'll do it. No, no, no, no. I
don't want to do it in a hacky way.
Like go to fucking Josh Joshua
tree and be like, hey man,
like look at the rock for me show.
No, no, don't, don't do that.
But I want to go to best buy and
get like last night freaking out,
looking at the screen,
you need to be a veteran at that point.
You don't go into a mall
with like fluorescent lights
or a shop like home depot
or Lowe's unless you're an
experienced tripper. Okay.
That's when incidents happen.
So if you go in there and
you've done this a few times,
you find yourself smirking
at the absurdity of places
like Lowe's or home depot,
strip malls.
There's things like this.
But if you go in there first time
and do that as your first name, uh,
don't call me for bail because
I could always shovels, man,
start freaking and they're
going to dig my grave.
Now the first time I actually,
uh,
I think actually was tripping a little
bit was I ingested weed and then went to
the airport to board in an
international flight night,
two and a half a pot brownies.
And I was just,
I too much. Yeah, it was way too much.
And I know I did some sort of brain damage
and I just never fucked with it again.
And I just, it felt like I had, you know,
like I told the story on Opie and
Anthony Long time ago, you know,
like when your foot
falls asleep really bad,
it felt like that was a ball of that,
like just sitting on my head like a,
you know, those, those, those things you
use in the shower, those big puffy things.
It felt like there was like that size
of it just sitting right on the crown on
my head.
And I was like,
we'd hung over for like two days cause
I went to Costa Rica and I got off and I
thought it was going to get arrested.
All those things.
It was like midnight express and all
that shit. But, um, yeah, so I just,
I always like booze cause you
know, I was a corny kid in, in,
in my world it was legal, you know,
like it's not a drug man. It's legal.
It's a simple high too. It's just like,
well I'm a simple guy. Yale. Yeah. Okay.
Sample high and there's a, there's
a, there's a spot for alcohol in,
in one's life. I would, I
would assume, but uh, yeah,
it gets a bit more complex
with psychedelics and weed
and shit like this. Um, uh,
and, and, and heroin
and at first, you know,
is it's really actually it's a psychedelic
at first and then it becomes a day to
day drag and routine, which a, you're not
using the drug. That drug is using you,
all these great cliches, blah, blah,
blah, blah. How long does that take?
When is the honeymoon over with heroin?
Oh,
well technically, uh,
looking back on my days,
a couple of decades of doing that,
I would say after the very
first hit, really? Oh No.
And then you spend the next 20 years
trying to recreate that first hit.
Now are you able to like try heroin?
Right? This is so bad for kids listening.
Were you able to try heroin
and walk away from it?
Is can people try it and walk away from
it and just be like, yeah, you know,
I did it. I just, yeah, I
think, I think there are,
and especially because the first
time you do it generally, uh, it, it,
it consumes the body.
So much that you're just so not
used to this kind of like forced,
uh, almost hyperloop tunnel
into the unknown that a,
you throw up,
a lot of people throw up their first time.
It's like you can like air sick as
you're teleporting into another reality.
Seriously. It's, it's
like that a lot of people,
like I remember the first time I got
drunk, I was like eight years old.
My parents had some kind of like sixties
kind of Tiki themed cocktail party for
their mess.
Sounds like drew Barrymore's childhood.
Somebody gives you an eight
ball, right? He turned, Hey,
let's get it from an eight ball.
Uh,
fall. Great parents. No, but
like I, I went around and,
and emptied all the drinks that people
had left at this Tiki themed party.
My parents,
I was about eight and I think they're
mainly drinking like some kind of gin
based relations, evil. Oh, it's evil evil.
And I drank that and I got so violently
sick that I never wanted to drink liquor
again. But here I am. I mean I still drank
liquor. It's the same thing with heroin.
It's like their first time you're going
to probably get sick because your body
is overwhelmed.
You sorta Halluc I always thought
it just made just super relaxed.
Like my only idea of it
wasn't trainspotting when
that guy shot up in the room,
he just fell into the rug and sunk into
the floor, which actually I was like, wow,
that looks amazing.
Yeah. Yeah, I like that.
I just can't deal with the side effects.
I mean that scene and get out
where like the, the lady hits the,
the teaspoon on the cup and then floats
down the chair of the black dude. And uh,
I mean you also have trips like that
on heroin. Heroin is actually an opiod.
I mean, Alistair Crowley and even, uh,
Lord Byron from like the 18th century,
they used to dabble and uh,
opiates, morphine back then.
And uh, just like, whoa. You know,
and there's bad trips and good trips,
but it is trip.
So except that a lot of the times
you're not awake during the Detroit,
so it's more like a
controlled or uncontrolled
dreamscape that you're having.
Even more uncontrolled, unusual.
How do your legs feel afterwards?
Like whenever I'm packing the day when
New York was New York and like every,
you know, 10th corner, there would be
a junkie just nodding out on heroin.
I remember Mark Marin uses this hilarious
bit about how they never tip over or
something like that, but I
don't, yeah. And the thing was,
but they would be in like doing
like the longest squat ever.
You know what I mean? You know, if
you do like a set of tennis squats,
like you're fucking thighs of burdens.
Like how does that feel? That's,
that's what I would think.
I wouldn't think, man, this
guy's fucking his life up.
It's minus 30 Audi has no coat on and
he's just standing this slowly going down
to the ground. Like how do you leg
slowly, how do you lay eggs? Yeah.
All right. Well, okay. What do they feel
like afterwards? Ask yourself this man.
Let's say transport yourself to the
Amazon jungle. You've got sloths there,
right?
That sit there and hang on this
one branch for like days at a time.
Right. Those things only
poop like once a week. I'm,
I'm thinking about getting one as a pet
so when I go on tour and so I just put a
diaper on him and I come home and I
don't have to clean anything up that just
have a slot hanging out.
He's only moved three feet over.
I love these animals, but it's just
the same thing as being a junkie.
You're very much like a sloth. And
I'll say this much for sloths. Uh,
you can test them all you want,
but they've been around for
over 3 million years now that,
is there a group of people out
there just trashing sloths?
I just like how you said you can do this.
You can talk shit about them all.
You will.
I've seen it.
I've seen it on the inner webs where
like people are like downright bashing
sloths. I'm like such a sad world.
Well, well that's capitalism.
That's America. It's like we don't like
sloths. We like go getters. You know,
if you count you fat, fuck, I'm
trying to make money off you
as well. That's what, that's what a
sloth is like being a junkie. And yes,
you can do superhuman feats of hang on
a tree branch for three days and you can
go into a squat position. You
probably thought like, you know what,
you're in an alley. You're high out of
your fucking mind on heroin and you go,
I gotta take a shit and you probably
start the squat and about three days later
you finally finish up
shit. Well, you know what?
The one thing that the one good side
effects of heroin seems to be if you
survive is you're kind of in shapes
borderline shredded for the rest of your
life.
What is that dude?
I every fucking guy that heavy rocks
I've ever seen that they had a 10 year
period on heroin. They're like
70. They had like 0% body fat.
They still have ads. It wasn't for
the old skin hanging off of them.
They could model underwear. Man,
you just described me perfect. Yeah.
Going to like it. But uh, no.
I asked William Burroughs,
what the fuck is going on around
here? They'll leave blower. Oh Geez.
I don't even know who that guy is. So
you should use the leaf blower. He's,
I think he's from Terminator Vibe.
It's probably how he breaks into houses.
That's his thing.
He just walks around with a leaf blower.
William Burroughs at 78 looked like he
did at 18 which at 18 he looked like he
was 78 but it never changed.
Right.
It was like this weird pickling and
although how had human attics get that,
they get pickled.
Not only was I on heroin,
but of course I was on the
Methadone program for 18
years, invented by the Nazis.
You know another thing to be,
you don't have a wrinkle on your face
too hilarious. But all this shit,
I'm fucking pickle and it's been 15
years since I even touch their shit.
I basically heard your podcast
last week bitching about like, oh,
you're 50 and you're,
let me tell you the next 10 years because
I'm going to be turning 60 this year.
You're in fucked fill now, man. No, I'm
going staying in my fifties no, I don't.
I know I'm carrying. How old are you
trying to Olga? Fuck. Oh No. Oh No.
You treat me like a slot right now. Now I
resent it. You're fucked. I mean just uh,
look, I'll get up and I ride
20 miles a day on a stationary.
Tell everybody what you watch when you
do it. Do remember you telling me this,
you were last time I talked to the show,
the reality show used to watch when
you would owe that 600 pound life.
So you'd sit there and watch and I mean
my wife started watching us. I was like,
Mia you have to shut this off cause I
watch biggest loser then they have are
funny fat they are. But they are funny
fan and the shower scenes, 600 pound life.
As soon as they focus in on a
girl named Kirsten or something,
then the next seven minutes are her
taking off her clothes and getting into a
shower. It's literally fat core porn
on TV know. And the thing is they don't
have like,
like with the guys,
they don't have to blur out anything
because they're fat covers, right.
It's like they have, they have like
a fucking speedo made out of fat. Oh,
I saw this one guy,
he was like,
can lean up against the wall in the shower
and his stomach hung all the way down
to his fucking ankles.
I mean,
yeah.
Oh my God.
And then they'd come in and the wife
will come in and she has like, you know,
that, that you, you know,
the do it yourself car wash where
they got that scrub brushes. They do,
we have one hand is lifting up
a roll of fat and she's just,
and the guys in there like,
ah,
like it's like he's trying to hold up
a refrigerator, but it's something,
it's himself. I love
that show that, and uh,
I'll ride every day to either a
600 pound life or body bizarre,
which is, what is that? Oh, that's,
that's things where people
have tails and eight legs,
uh, joined at the hip to head. I was
like, birth defects. Yeah. Allen,
what do they call it?
And uh, uh, body bizarre.
You gotta chill. They went to PT Barnum.
They were like, okay, birth defects.
I don't feel like people are gonna
Watch it if we call that. Totally. It's,
it's the only thing to ride too.
If you want to do an exercise program,
just like watch that
shit and ride and just,
you feel better about like trying to
do something for yourself, you know,
it's just like, wow, these people have
really gone to shit. I'm kicking ass.
I would love to hear them brainstorming
for that show a weird bodies now.
Now let's get alliteration going.
Body Bonanza body. Bizarre. Bizarre.
Yeah. I don't, uh, I don't know.
I actually dropped some weight since
last time I saw you. Hey look good.
And I'm going to try. I totally
fucking dragged that compliment Nadia.
I laid off the booze for like four months
and now I've been like trying to eat,
uh, staying away from the breads and
all that gluten shit. And I actually,
you know, as much as that's a big
Hollywood thing, I feel a lot better.
But every once in a while I'll fucking,
you know,
I'll eat a pizza and it's delicious.
I can never just like totally walk away.
Like,
what?
I'm never going to have a pizza again
and I'm not going to eat that stupid
gluten free one. That's like fat Dan. This
gluten free. What is what, what is that?
I mean it's like Vladimir Gluten.
That's all I know is all my friends
are fucking Vladimir Gluten.
Their dictator is on there.
I don't know what it is.
I just know I'm losing weight doing
it and I eat that Ezekiel bread,
which just tastes like ass.
I mean it's really just like,
it's like if you took bread and stuck
it in a microwave and all the nutrients
left. Um, but you know, if
you put enough shit on it,
if you put a little almond butter on it,
it does taste good.
And I am losing weight.
I don't know,
but I feel like I'm still eating salads
and shit. It's like, remember when people,
people were on like that, that, what
was that diet where it's like, dude,
I can eat taken all day as long as I
don't eat this. And it's just like, yeah,
the Atkins Diet. Yeah, they had
car. Yeah. No carbs, no cars. Yeah.
It spawned a whole beer
industry of low carb beer. Yes.
Where you like shit out of cow head at
the end of the fucking day. Horns at all.
Yeah. I remember my watching
my friends doing that.
I just remember thinking
like that can't be good.
Like just eating meat all
the fucking time. Like they,
they didn't seem like they were eating
salads. They would just sit in there.
They we'd like eating bacon and like
Turkey and not saying any of that Shit's
bad. Cause who knows at this point there's
guys out there that stick and now like
they're putting melted butter
into their coffee. Oh God, I know.
No,
but they're saying that like that all of
that saturated fat shit that they were
saying is now a myth. It's like,
it's like the egg in my lifetime.
The egg when he times is the egg been in
and out and out and Andy over the month
or not.
It's like John Travolta's career to John
Travolta fucking Saturday night fever,
sweat hogs.
Right.
Then he fucking went away in the 80s that
he came back with pulp fiction than he
did fucking battlefield earth.
And I don't know what he's doing now,
but I feel like he's
going to come back again.
You know what, I'm, I'm actually
one of the few people that, dude,
this is embarrassing.
This is probably the most embarrassing
thing you're going to get me to say on
this pod. I love it. Is I actually
liked battlefield earth. Oh, you did?
I never saw it. I thought Forrest
Whitaker is in it for God's sake.
Okay. Barry peppers in it. Barry Pepper's,
none of these guys want us to mention
that, but those are all great actors. Yes.
Great actors.
And it was written by all Ron Hubbard,
which is basically the same thing
that is, uh, ancient aliens.
Guy Zacharias Cichon wrote in
his book the 12th Planet, uh,
about how we've been colonized for 400,000
years starting in South Africa where
they took apes and genetically made
them into like gold mine workers because
they needed gold dust to protect
their, uh, uh, plant, uh, the, the,
the ozone on their planet or some
kind of crazy shit. Either way.
It's totally believable to me. I mean, I
don't care one way or the other, you know,
but like,
but,
but that included with all those good
actors in this kind of tie in to sounded
like star wars mixed with roots mixed
with mushrooms mixed with mushrooms.
There you go. I actually like
battlefield earth. I remember a avoid.
So that's what that movie was
about. Yeah, yeah. It was like a,
a colonizing a dumb ass humans,
which they just made from
apes through their DNA and uh,
and had them all like mining gold for,
because they needed the gold on
their home planet and this and that.
And John Travolta had dreads just like
I got now. Right. It was like, no,
I'm thinking that movie.
It was pretty cool.
And I remember getting a lot
of shit for it going, Oh,
I'm all for this movie at the time.
And now it's like, okay, I'm going
perishingly admitting that.
Yeah, that was pretty cool. Well,
what's really interesting to
plot is interesting. So wait,
the Scientologists think
that we came from apes,
I thought they'd throw some
sort of spatial. Okay. Oh
yeah, yeah. There's a spaceship that
comes down and they needed, uh, they,
they tried to have their own people mind
these gold mines and these people just
said, fuck you. I want to go back to my
home planet. This is bullshit work, man.
This is like, this is like working as
a Barista at Starbucks or Mcdonald's.
And so get these age to do
it that are already on the planet.
And so they genetically engineered them
to be a little bit smarter and then they
started mining the gold and those
guys could hang out and drink.
So is that where my tax money's going?
Yeah. He's going to another planet.
Black projects, man. Black projects are
all over the place. What a black projects.
Ah,
you know,
all the shits like Alex Jones is on about
every day except he's way off the mark.
But just like what?
They don't think that guys hit the nail
on the head over there. Why not a 10?
I mean, he's swinging big. Yeah,
he's swinging big over there.
It was in the major leagues. His batting
average would be about one 39. I know,
but when he connects, but when
he connects, you know it's going,
it's leaving the park.
That's why you go. Yeah.
Do you want to see a guy swinging like
that out of right out of his fucking
cleats. That's it, man. I can't listen. I
used to be into all of that shit and like,
I see you guys. What are
we watching? MSNBC and a,
I like how they walk around
now when they're doing the
news to add some level of
excitement to it. Uh, ESPN does it.
They all fucking, they all walk around.
I don't watch any of that.
This shit. All right. First read of
the week here and don't cheat. Oh,
uh, talk about how made to
measure suits compared to generic.
Off The rack suits.
Well,
unless you're the exact same size as
a mannequin, which most people aren't,
it's just an impossible body. Him,
it's just not going to fit right.
So if you get it a made to measure,
you're going to look great. Uh,
Indochino is the largest
custom apparel company.
They make suits and shirts made your
exact measurements for a great fit.
Guys love the wide selection of high
quality fabrics and the options to
personalize all the details, including
lapel jacket, lining, monogram, and much,
much more. Here's how it works.
Works. You pick your fabric,
choose your customization, submit
your measurements, place your order,
and wait for it to arrive
in three weeks or less.
You can shop@indochino.com or visit any
of their showrooms across North America
this week.
My listeners can get any premium Indochino
suit for 359 bucks@indochino.com when
entering burp you are are at checkout.
That's over 50% off the regular price
for premium made to measure suit plus
shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo
code bar for any premium suit,
just three and $59 plus free shipping.
Incredible deal for a perfectly
tailored suit. Indochino I. N, D, O, c,
h. I. N. Oh look who's here.
It's our old friends, old zip,
right?
Are you hiring,
posting your position to job sites and
waiting and waiting for the right people
to see it?
Ziprecruiter knew there was a smarter way,
so they built a platform that finds
the right job candidate for you, zip
learns that you're looking for,
learns what you're looking for,
identities of people with
the right experience and
invites them to apply to the
job. Uh, these invitations
to have revolutionized how
you find next hire. In fact,
80% of employees who post on Zip, Huh? Uh,
get a quality candidate through the
site in just one day and zip recruiter's
doesn't stop there. They even spotlight
the strongest applications you receive,
so you never miss a great match.
That's right candidate.
The right candidates are out there.
Ziprecruiter is how you find them.
Call to action. Businesses
of all sizes, trust, zip
for their hiring needs.
Right now my listeners can try zip
for free. That's right. Free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/burr.
That's ziprecruiter.com/bird
ziprecruiter.com/bar zip,
[inaudible] dot com the smartest
one. Oh, look who's back.
It's our old friends.
Old Dollar Shave club dude.
Jolly shape club is better than
shopping in this show. Woah.
Jolly Shave club delivers to
you everything you need to look,
smell and feel your best
shampoo, body wash, toothpaste,
and of course the best
razors I have ever used.
I get an amazing high quality shape
every morning from my dollar shave club
executive.
Um,
but the true hero of my morning routine
has to be that doctor cabbies easy. Shea,
it helps to raise her gently
crop glide across your skin.
Please don't use this as on, on your
balls. Uh, you have to experience it.
Another must have experiences. How Dollar
Shave Club delivers everything to you.
That means no more trips to the store,
wandering the aisles, hunting for razors,
shampoo, toothpaste, and having
to play a at being a cashier,
scanning and bagging your own stuff.
Fuck all that shit.
For a mind blowing experience.
Just joined dollar Shave Club today
and for just $5 with free shipping,
you'll get the six blade executive razor
plus a trial sizes of shave butter,
body cleanser, and one white child. Uh,
then keep the blades coming
for a few bucks more a month.
Get yours@dollarshaveclub.com slash
burr that's dollar shave club.com/burr.
Okay, lastly, but of course not.
Leastly stamps.com everybody,
the US Postal Service is an important
tool for any business reaching every
household every day.
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service right to
your fingertips. Buy and print official
US postage for any letter, any package,
any class of mail using your
own computer and printer stamps.
Dot coms makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale automatic
that automatically calculates the
exact postage.
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage
meter and there are no long term
commitments.
I use stamps.com whenever I going to
sell posters or whatever the hell I do at
the end of my shows,
I'm,
and I'm a morning if I can figure out
how to help him to send these God damn
things out. Um, so can,
and right now you can enjoy the
stamps.com service was the special offer.
That includes a four week trial
plus postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com.
Click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com
enter
Berg.
Okay. And that's the ad reads.
And now back to the podcast.
Do you know I was talking to you
today on my podcast? Like what was it?
Will Sharon
before or fire right there?
There was a bunch of pro second amendment
people just standing and they just
were yelling America love it or
leave it. Right. And uh, I just like,
the whole thing that's fascinating
to me is that, you know,
these guys rotors amendment way
back in the day and it's just like,
well shit does evolve. I mean, it was an
amendment. So they were, weren't they?
There was a change to what
already existed and like he, you,
you do have to adjust because
I don't have, I don't have,
cause I don't have a problem with guns.
I don't have a problem with
the argument right away.
Is there on the corner yelling
America love it or leave it.
So they obviously don't love it because
they're on a corner at fucking four or
five on Wilshire yelling. So they don't
love it. So why don't they leave it?
They just get, because Norway doesn't
fucking want them. Oh, all right.
I don't know. I don't, that's why did
they not have guns out there in Norway?
How do they keep their people under
control? No guns. I know, I look,
I don't have a, yeah, I don't think
there's anything wrong with guns.
If you fucking own them responsibly,
they just have to figure out a way.
If they could just figure out a fucking
way to make sure that these fucking
lunatics who then go on social media
saying, I'm going to do this shit.
And everybody kind of ignores it. Ah, hey
man, it's, it's this, it's this simple.
If you get a couple of Duis, they
take your license away, right?
If you're going to get a gun and you've
had a couple batteries, assaults,
domestic shit,
all sorts of crappy stuff,
and you torture and animals as a child
and you've been thrown out of five
schools,
probably not a good idea to get a gun.
I have nothing against guns
either. I mean, look, uh, you know,
if you're some grizzly Adams type of
living in a cabin in Colorado shooting
grizzly bears for Hyde's food
tent sustenance, this and that,
good on Ya. You know, you're probably
a responsible gun owner. Oh, he's cute.
He's going to create the next people can
guys that like this all goes to shit,
got beat up too much in high school.
They weren't part of the cool clique.
They started making threats on Youtube,
this and that and the other.
They beat up their wives, their
girlfriends, this and that.
They beat up their moms. They've, you
know, don't give him a fucking gun.
Joined a band.
Yeah.
Get into show business like the rest of
us were presently hiring roadies now.
Well speaking to that before we get
all sideways here, but the politics,
I can't fucking hear myself anymore.
He let me take this out,
put it back and come on your best today.
Where is it? Where's the sweet spot?
There is um, you got a new
album coming up. Oh yeah. Right.
Tell us, tell us the name. Tell us
about it. I listened to one track.
I love the harmonica on it.
Then haunting like with the,
with the reverb on it and stuff.
Uh,
I don't know what,
whatever the name of the track was,
but maybe why it made me call twilight
zone. It made me want to go play drums.
That's how I know I like a sock is I
immediately go into fantasy mode and
whatever cool thing is happening,
I'm doing it.
So at first I was playing drums and
then when you did the harmonica part,
then that was me and my fantasy.
I was playing that and everybody was
gazing up at the stage going, wow,
look how awesome bill is. So you're one
for one. That could still happen. Oh,
okay. Now I know we've all heard you to
come onstage before and you pussied out.
I didn't pussy out. What are you talking
about? Why that Danzig at that? Uh,
whatever. I couldn't make it
down there. Oh this is the thing.
If you want look like we were ready to
bring you a helicopter to fly down on the
stage and have you come
back and play drums for us.
Now that you said I'm a
pussy, I'll, I'll do it.
I'm playing a little bit of double
bass now. I just don't want to ruin it.
I don't want to ruin it because people
come in there to see you like and that
you knew what it wants to cause you were
doing a festival so I figure you played
a shorter set. Yay. But if you'll go
on there and it's a full on you show,
if you have some jerk off comic,
come on for one song.
I think the crowd can handle
that. But if it's just like, hey,
we only got time for six songs, and
on one of them, the guy from VH ones,
I love the 80 strikes back
is going to play drums.
And I know you guys might
get a kick out of that.
I'm just worried that you fans like what,
what they're gonna fucking
throw at me when I'm up there.
But my favorite guest appearance
for us of all time was, uh,
during Lollapalooza we had a
Kirk Hammett from Metallica.
Oh Wow. Come on stage. We'd
known Kirk for a while and we,
we'd opened up from Metallica
on a bunch of dates in Europe.
And so we got to be friends and,
and,
and Kirk came out and we did a cover of
a black sabbath song called super not at
a festival. Uh, and,
and we're playing it and we gave
him the second lead in the song.
So he started going crazy.
I mean, his hair was flying.
It looked like he had one
of those industrial blow
dryers on his hair and there
was a whole blow dryer. It just, his
hair was flinging around. He was into it.
He was into it and all that,
but it just went on for fucking ever and
so the rest of the band was just like,
well fuck it.
We're out of here.
So we all just walked off and by the,
by the time he realized what was happening
and he's still in the middle of his
lead,
there's no band members up there and we're
all standing there on the side of the
stage, like looking at our
watches going, dude, really?
This is now like going on a 12
minute solo. You fucking, oh no.
So then we'll wait. What
point? He told me later.
It's like he didn't want to leave the
stage because he realized he was going to
get shit when he left, so we might
as well keep going at that point,
I think it wound up to be
like a 17 minutes. So locally,
because I knew he was going to
get his ass beat on this things.
If you guys leave and then he doesn't
leave, it looks like it's planned. Right?
Well, it wasn't planned.
We were just bored
right now. What is the
etiquette? If somebody goes to
see, you know, five, eight,
you've been in a fucking that to me,
if you guys that would be a Larry Self,
you leave me out there and I'll be up
there. Boom, crack, crack. I sit along,
I can do that before I get killed.
That's when you start incorporating
the Tom Thompson shows that what I do,
what I would do is I would just, I would
do a backward somersault off the stool,
crawl my way out underneath the curtain.
Did he get mad at you guys or do
you think it was funny? No, he was,
he was scared shitless by the
time he got off and then we're,
we all acted pest and now it's just like,
ah, that was fun man. You know, and just,
but he was kind of scared at first, but
uh, he's never come back this ever since.
He just got back on stage. We don't get
a lot of guest artist anymore. Well,
I'm sure he told that story.
I'm imagining that that went around.
I don't know if he didn't want to repeat
that story. He was pretty freaked out.
Uh,
I have told it anyway.
So you've got this new album
coming out when it comes out on on,
was it March 6th when it comes out? March
nights. Nights? Yeah. It's a Friday.
Okay. Very nice. He night
shrooms. Woo. That's right.
Shroom weekend. And where can,
where can people get it? Oh, I guess
everywhere. I don't know. Oh God. I mean,
what are you really creative guys on
the worst promoted we'll share with uh,
with a billboard and start hawking cds.
I mean,
I don't know where these things are sold.
What was it going to be on a diet?
They are sold anymore. They just like,
you know, by the time we post this,
I'm sure someone will give me a link
and I'll be able to tell people where to
get it. I mean, I, you've been in this
business long enough that you know,
that the whole purpose of this is to
get people to hear your shit, man.
I've been in this business long enough
to also know that I don't really give a
fuck about this part of the business.
Okay. I just kinda like do what I do.
And you know now you were influenced by,
like I always heard those guys
you were talking about, oh,
Bill Burroughs as you call him William
Burroughs, right? Yeah, it didn't,
those guys, they would write type
out a bunch, oh, pages, story,
and then they would cut up all the,
every word individually.
They throw it in the air and
then tape it all together. Yeah,
and then they would just start
writing from that, you know? No, that,
that's what I did
on in 1980 was it 88 or some shit
around like land of rape and honey.
I decided to do an album like that
based on William Burroughs riding,
which is how I hooked up with him later.
I just took a bunch of pieces of tape.
Yes.
We actually use tape back then,
not just digital and just cut it all up
into various pieces and threw it on the
floor,
spilled coffee on,
I'm snorting coke off of them or did
whatever and then put them back together.
Some were backwards, somewhere
forward, some worse, some not,
and then put it together in
an actually told a narrative,
which is what bill Burroughs was saying.
I almost did it as an experiment gone.
This guy is crazy.
That can't just happen.
Like he's just throw shit random
on the floor and it talks to you,
but 90% of the time it
seemed to work like wow,
like you couldn't have done that
yourself. So it's like you're, you're,
you're throwing yourself to like random
chance of it coming out good. Yeah,
sometimes it does.
Why don't you get the balls to do that?
You got a record deal
and everybody is trying
so hard to do it the way
that everybody's doing it.
You have the ability to do it that way.
How did you get the balls to be like, ah,
well you independent at that point
so you could take that kind of rest.
He just didn't care. I, I'd done a couple
records for major labels at that point.
I did this horrific record where they
took over the whole thing out for errors
to records. Then I did this other
record for Warner Brothers that, uh,
pretty much gave me carte blanche,
but it was still like learning
to crawl before you walk.
By the time I got to that record,
I was just sick of all these people.
I figured like if,
if these are the people that
claimed to know what they're doing,
then I must be fucking Einstein
because these people are adults.
So I just decided to do whatever the
fuck I wanted to do, you know? Right.
So how did you come up with, uh, what
does, what does that song, uh, uh,
I'm the fucking worst.
It said thing.
We stigmata that guitar riff on that.
I always thought the guy had a slide at
Donna, an aunt, my aunt and I, yeah, that,
that is a sliding and somebody
told me, you sped it up. Well,
I did that too.
And I also added a Didgeridoo
onto that to get that slide.
I get really meticulous on my show. That's
one of the sickest riffs of all time.
I played that for my wife and she
was like, what the fuck is this?
This is awesome. And then you went
way over the top and then, you know,
then she kind of left it that,
well back then people weren't
using distortive vocals either.
And that was actually quite the accident
because, uh, we, we had this cheap,
Sony asked Mike that ran on batteries and
the batteries were low and when I went
to sing that first scream, it just
sounded like a cat was being tortured.
Like bill, it sounds great.
Let's keep it, you know. So we,
and then we started trying to replicate
that sound for the next 10 years.
You know,
it's Kinda like your first heroin hit
in the next 10 years.
I think we should have kept that
microphone in those batteries.
So what did you do?
You just use like the bull horn?
Cause I've seen the clips of your,
your live shows are unbelievable
and their Osa terrifying.
Like I love him. That gave me
the chills as I'm watching it.
But then there's a part of me going,
you know,
I'm glad I wasn't in like
that fucking pit down front.
Cause especially the way I look back
then I look like fucking ruin Howard way
back in the day before it looked like a
itch injury. Rent our, our pit is like a,
it's scary for us too. We looked at
these fucking kids and we're like,
uh, you know, like, like I said,
I'm pushing 60 and I'm looking at these
20 year old kids and I'm thinking like
these could be literally physically
my grandkids and I'm worried about our
future. And so what, what's,
what a bit on stage man.
What's some of the weirdest shit or
scary shit you've seen when you were on
stage? Um, you know what? No, no,
I don't have anything that's like
particularly like, like a, you know,
hear about like what was, there's
some rap concert the other day that a,
they stopped the concert because they saw
a girl being raped in the front row or
we're in the pit or something
like that. And uh, uh, I've never,
how does that happen? Like the other
people don't see that it is so large.
What riff were they playing that everyone
was so locked into it that there's
literally somebody getting raped next to
you and you can't see it? I don't know.
I don't understand that. I've never
seen anything like that. Actually.
Some of the stairway, uh, stay.
Would it have been maybe people love
that one that they just waiting for that
drum fill? Well, well that,
that would be like, uh, it,
uh, if, if I saw something really
weird on a stairway to heaven song,
uh,
at a led Zeppelin concert,
it would probably be a hobbit being raped
in the pit because I never understood
this about led Zeppelin. Don't take me
wrong, I love the fucking band, but,
uh, this guy, basically his
lyrics, we've given them a pass.
All these things about his
dungeons, dragons, castles, maidens,
horses,
and his Dick.
It's and his tick that squeeze
my lemon or whatever. I mean,
I mean, this guy's really coasted,
this Robert Plank Guy Matt here,
and I love the fucking band. Don't take,
did you ever get to see them? Oh yeah,
of course. And then they just
amazing. What tours did you
see them on the page? Uh,
I saw him at the Chicago
Stadium and like what? 75,
76, 77, something like that. I mean,
so bottom had the vista light at that
point, right? The orange seethrough one?
No, he was strutting around and he's, Oh,
a little bit drunk. He gets better. Well,
while they were in town.
Okay.
They spent three days in Chicago and
he did his show at the Chicago Stadium,
the old stadium and a, I once saw that
and then I had to work at wax tracks.
So the, no, so this is like 79.
So he's got the stainless
steel kit? No, no, no.
He was walking around with like a little,
uh,
like girly top tied off around mid torso.
And then, uh, uh, Robert Plant,
I think some of them bought them.
I'm telling my bell bottoms there were
as wide as this coffee table and he's
strutting around doing all this stuff.
And at that point he's in
his mid to late forties. Um,
and I just thought like, um, I just
thought, damn it, this is inappropriate.
He was funny. He wasn't, he was only like
30 or 31 well he was born in like 48,
mid forties so maybe you should have
stuck to heroin because he wasn't picky,
easy turning around and I'm going
like, that's like, uh, he's,
he's doing like this chicken dance and
stuff on here and singing about hobbits
and, and I, I immediately zoned
out and paid no attention.
He just listened to like the tightness
of the band and you can plant did get old
quick though. He was like a young guy
and then right after physical graffiti,
he just got all the lines in his face.
Yeah, it's weird. I think that's genetic.
So I think that's that, that's kind of
like a Nordic thing. I think he must be,
have Nordic Dna because that's what
happens to Scandinavian people.
They look so awesome when they're young
and then because their genetics tell
them like when they're old,
they've spent 40 years of Nordic
winters and their skin says,
fuck you, I'm cracking wrinkling
now. They just needed some lotion,
but he looks cool now though. He needs
lotion, but he looks cool now though.
It looks great now he found the low
sheer, but he never, yeah, you could,
but you can tell his face. He never did
heroin. Yeah. He didn't give hope. Gone.
I got,
that's hilarious.
You can look at old people and
tell the drugs that they did. Um,
well, a, I, you're also,
a lot of people might not know this
about you is you're a huge hockey fan or
they literally in the house
building shit right now. Yeah. Yeah.
This is destruction zone one.
This is, let's call we've done,
we've done almost 40 minutes before the
hammering started saying, Oh, you know,
and Rassie brought up led Zepplin hammer
of the gods. Oh, right, right there. Huh?
Jesus. Oh yeah. That was, that
was a book that put me to sleep.
I believed every word of
it. Oh, I do too. Get Sleep.
It's compared to like the shit we did
and not only just us talking to you put a
shark in a woman and then
what happened? It, well,
what's the water is shark.
It was a dolphin. No, no, no.
It was a bathtub.
Plastic Shark.
And One of our roadies was
penetrating a girl willingly.
There was no rape. I wasn't about
us, not about zipline. Oh No,
I'm talking about our tour.
And I've seen,
I've seen some crazy shit. I mean,
that's unfolding five random.
That is that I sprouted bringing
in a shark, putting it in a woman.
Who the fuck does that? And you
actually had a story, you know? Yeah.
It wasn't a real shark. It was
a toy shark. And it wasn't me.
And it wasn't the band that was on,
we had two buses.
We had the road crew boss and
the ban shark bus and, and,
and the band bus basically had some
kind of decorum going on, but the,
the crew bus was literally, Dante is
ninth gate of Hell. I mean, you know,
walk on there. And it was just like
calendula on steroids going out.
Oh Wow. That shit that you'd see. And I
just don't wander because like, say I'd,
I'm out of,
I'm out of smokes.
I go in to borrow a pack of smokes from
one of the roadies because none of the
bands smokes.
And so I'd go and I'd walk in and just
walk into like Dante's inferno stepping
through an orgy to get a human
mind field of fornication.
Try not to step on anybody's fucking
heads. Um, yeah. Well, you know,
I'm actually, uh, I,
I've had the exact opposite experience on
the road where it's just been a lonely,
isolated thing, but I was kind
of built for the lay people.
Somebody was asking you about that shit.
You know about being on the road and
like groupies and stuff. It's just like,
dude, that just doesn't fucking, it's
different. It can fuck me. It's just not,
it's not what like to,
you guys go up there with a fucking
Ukulele and you just fucking
brown and all of a sudden this
fucking panties flying at you.
You know what's true? I'm not saying
you, I'm not saying you, but you know me.
I get just bolts and coins and bottles
flying at me. I don't get panicked.
I'm not stuck. Um, you know,
some fucking jerk off could go to a
God damn coffee house on an open mic.
All right. And he can fucking go
up there with the Ukulele. It's,
he could literally do his cover,
probably do a reggae version
of a Mama and papa song. Right.
All the leaves of Brown man. Right. And
they don't even get to the next to that.
And the next thing you know,
there's be some woman is
going to fuck a respond to it,
you know w yeah. But how many
people do you travel with when,
when you go on the road? Nobody. I go
by myself. I am like have a handler. No,
I have like open it. Nah, it's
just more people I got to talk to.
I don't have a look. If I go to another
country and I don't mean Canada. Yeah.
I mean another country. I uh, wait, no,
when I did Canada, they get, they
gave like a road person. I, I,
it drives me up the fucking wall. Uh, but
when I'm in another country, I love it.
When I was in Australia,
the guy had was fucking awesome and I'm
definitely gonna use him again when I
was like,
I cover my bases here so that they can
be shit coming from the stage with you.
In other words, he traveled alone.
You just go home to Australia.
I'm going a lot if I'm going
to Australia. What? I love it.
I love having a tour manager because he
shows up and it's just like, all right,
this is what you need to be. Boom. I
don't have to worry about anything.
And there's transportation.
Um, when I go into England,
I've had great people and all of that
type of stuff, pray, people, Scandinavian,
all that shit. But in the states,
no, I just show up on the wall.
I get a rent a car, like fucking
Chuck Berry drive up with my mic,
stand in the car. That keeps the
overhead low. That's the thing.
That's where things get dicey when
like our, our touring parties,
about 17 people between band and crew and,
uh,
there's generally three
or four rookies on,
on each tour. And the rookies have
read too many books like Hammer.
The gods are, yeah. Yeah.
And so they bring that,
that that shit onto the buses.
Mainly on the crew boss. Uh,
we haven't had,
we've had the most boring band
bus for probably about almost 12,
13 years. Thank God. Because
did you guys sit there and playing
like cards against humanity?
Like that's a crazy night
actually.
You know what? No, we, we just,
we get the fuck off the bus.
We stay in our little areas and get the
fuck off the bus and go to the hotel as
soon as possible.
And then,
then are like stupid shit happens at
the hotel bar. Not so much on the bus.
The bus is like, kind of like
this. I'm a big hotel bar guy.
I love it because it's like
you're already kind of home.
It's like you downstairs
in your own kitchen and,
and then you can just drink down there
and then just tell bar tenders are always
like, I don't even, I think their,
they're good. Right? Oh, at
least at the hotels he stayed,
I'd say Sheridan's Hilton's this and
that. Radissons, blah, blah, blah.
We reached at that, that kind of shit.
Those hotel bartenders in every city are,
are like, they must've taken a class
because they're all real similar.
They're all psychology based,
drink pour.
My favorite hotel bar is the one you can,
you can be like staying on the 10th
floor and you can look down over at the
elevator to see if it's still open.
You know,
those ones rather than half of all the
way down and you'll just see these drunk
sitting down. And I had still going
here. Then we got to get gone down.
You don't have to call anybody or
anything like that. So, um, hey,
is there a cause I do want
to promote your album, man.
I think you're a fucking genius.
So is there any sort of theme on this one?
Is it just, uh, yeah, look man,
I mean I've been known to bash our,
uh,
right wing friends before and are right
wing leaders such as George Bush and
Ronald Reagan and things
in the past. But uh, this,
this one is not real anti Trump.
It's more like what kind of system
keeps producing these people?
Uh, let, let's uh, let's
cut to the quick here.
It's the system that keeps producing
these people that we keep thinking is a
good idea to be our spokesperson
for our ideals and a,
and the quality of these people
keeps going down and down and down.
So rather than a attack,
it is fallen off where we,
we at least we had like low bar, we add
like we used to have career politician,
then we went to like the boss's son.
Yeah.
And now we've got like a reality show,
like a TV star and now,
which is causing all these people
out here in Hollywood to go like,
I want to run like the second you say
you want to run for president. Yeah.
Your body and mind you,
you're basically saying,
you saying I want to have dead bodies
on my conscience because that's what the
fuck you signing up for.
And I'm not saying that you're going to
have to go out and do the wrong thing,
but like in the process
of doing the right thing,
you're going to kill people that
would just in the wrong place.
That's why I think they age the way
they do it because it's like it's heavy.
Yeah. Fucking heavy. I get asked this
question all the time in interviews.
All right, Mr Political, what would,
what's the first thing you'd
do if you were president?
I'd fucking quit. He could.
I don't want any part of this shit.
I put the solar panels back on the White
House and then I'd leave. Yeah. Okay.
I will and I'll do a, personally,
I would do that and I would get,
I'd have the guy,
the chef to the chef make me a sandwich
and I want to ride in the helicopter and
then that's it.
I now introduce you to the vice president
and the person who will now be running
all of this shit. You gotta throw
one party in on Air Force One, one,
one big kind.
It looks like a giant like fucking thing.
I always fly in the Marine One helicopter.
Always look bad ass to me.
You're old enough to remember it.
Old Seven 47 fleet of via ever fly seven
47 I went to jail or you got to go to
the Ronald Reagan Library on, you
know, they have that. They have,
they have literally the one that he sat
on talking to Gorbachev or get to go
upstairs to that bar and hang out with
the cool people or you're a fly on that
seven 47 I'd always wanted to do,
I did that one time.
I got busted twice and sent
right back down. You know,
it was a spiral staircase and you went,
you went up there and everybody had
suits in this fucking stewardesses.
We'll hot bath. Yeah. When
we were, uh, I did this,
this run through Asia, I did, um, um,
the fuck did I, Singapore, Hong Kong and
then Mumbai, India and leaving Mumbai,
India. We connected through Dubai and we
got on that Air Emirates. Oh, that, that,
that's not even an airline at w it's
like a w hotel with like with wings.
Yeah. It's fucking unreal.
So, and that's even like, it,
it's better than a w w was like a w
hotel like acts like it's nice. It's,
it's like nice if you
were in your twenties,
you see a lot of fucking very twenties,
a lot of aquarium lighting around
the bed and shit. But so we, we were,
uh, we were, I came up, we were upstairs
or whatever. All I remember was we,
uh, when, if I were going to fly
that far, I use all the miles,
every fucking thing I can possibly
do, make less money. Yeah.
I'm going to sit at least have
one of those bed shares. And um,
so I got up to go to the bathroom and I
walked in the back to go to the bathroom
and they had like the
semicircular bar. Yeah. Like,
cause it was one of those wide body.
So there was like chair two
chairs next to the window,
then an aisle than the middle
than an aisle and then all of a,
so that middle section it was,
is that,
it was that wide in the back where it
had like a semicircle and a bartender in
there.
And they had a little bench seat and some
stools around their bench seat with a
seatbelt that you sat down on.
So I saw it.
You were up there and I went back.
I didn't have the one go autograph.
I didn't have the one where you had to
like your own apartment like that one.
That one's like 15 grand one way this.
So, um, I went back and I got my wife,
I said, Hey, can I, uh, can
I buy you a drink? She goes,
well, you're talking about,
go come with me. So we went
to the back. We were like,
she and she just ear to ear grin
and I ordered a couple mixed drinks.
We sat down on the little bench seat.
I put a seatbelt on,
put mine on and we just sat there.
We didn't have that many,
but it was just so fucking cool.
It's w it didn't seem possible.
It's like I at a bar in the sky.
I know they flying drones
flying to New York.
It was one of those things where I was
very excited to get back to the states,
but that was definitely one that I didn't
want it to end. Where you just like,
oh my God.
It's the exact opposite of riding and
coach where it's like you could literally
be flying from like fucking New York to
Buffalo. Did your neck start hurting to,
sorry,
it was sitting side by side.
I came by that mustache. Oh, okay. And uh,
I don't know what you're doing. You're
taking stuff out from underneath the uh,
all right then my love to say
what's going on right? I don't know.
He took legal. Is it legal?
I don't know what it is.
It looks like he has all that
is wine or didn't think of it.
I thought that was like liquid weed.
You're going to pour into the vaporizer
and it reaches a certain temperature.
Let me tell you something,
man,
you are fucking rock star because I've
never had an experience that good flying.
The closest thing I ever had was I did
an 18 hour flight to Australia once and I
was on the last fucking flight
that allowed smoking on nine seats,
only on nine seats in business class.
So it wasn't,
first class wasn't coach and they had
nine seats arranged on Quantus for people
who smoke. And if I'm going
to be 18 hours on an airplane,
I want to fucking cigarette.
You know nowadays you got the
East cigs and it's really easy.
Nobody knows your fucking like nicotine
out of your mind on these planes. Right?
Cause I'm a flyer and puffing on my east
egg and nobody bothers me and I don't
bother anyone else. But this was the
last smoking flight Quantis ever had.
It was actually in the news and I was one
of the people that had those seats and
a,
so I get there and there's
this businessman from Hong
Kong next to me and he
immediately starts blowing his nose on
the tray in front of them and there's
boogers and shit all over the sheet
in front of me can just notice.
And I was just like, stewardess, man,
I can't sit next to this fucking guy.
Okay. He's, he was really
weird. It was rude.
Oh yeah. The, I think you're
being really nice about this guy.
It's just define that as weird and rude
and,
and the,
the flight was booked so they put me on
one of those comic Kasi sheets at the
stewardess just sit on right
before they do a little jump seat,
a little jump seat. So they put me in
there. So I was like, all right, cool.
Why don't they sit the her up?
They're like, well that's the point.
So like I'm sitting there and I light up
a smoke and they just like flipped out.
Like you can't be smoking here.
Like what are you doing? I'm like,
well I'm not sitting
next to that fucking guy.
So we had this like two hour standoff
and they tried to get the guide and move
and he wouldn't move. And so they finally
acquiesce since it was the last flight,
which smoking, I got to sit there
on the jump seat and just change.
That was like my rock star flying story.
Man with Hong Kong,
you know when I flew from Singapore
to Hong Kong, I'm defensive Hong Kong.
This guy might've been from Singapore,
he might've been from New Hampshire,
I didn't talk to him, but up in the
uh, the lounge there, they had a,
they had these fucking,
they would make a dump like all right,
the fucking dumplings that
they make over there dude.
And they literally think if you dropped
them, if they would like float plane, no,
in the, in the airport.
Right, right, right, right.
So they keep coming out with
these dumplings and this
motherfucker keeps going
up to and he would like take
seven out of eight of them.
He was a skinny bastard and he
was just fun. It was like a,
do you remember about Paul Newman and uh,
uh, get mad at them eggs. Cool Hand Luke.
He was eating them like fucking hand.
Luke just sticking up down his fucking
throat and they were delicious and it was
just like every time they
would bring them out,
I would have to like look over to make
sure I could go up there just to get some
for me and my wife. So this guy
must've been like 20 or 30 days,
he'd fucking eat the whole
time he was up there,
he child those goddamn
things and it, uh, I dunno,
it Kinda put me in a
mood like I was calling,
this is what Hong Kong
is going to be like,
a bunch of selfish people eating
all the fucking dumplings.
But then I had to quickly be like,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
There's selfish assholes from
where I'm from and I'm one of them.
So maybe I'm going to the promise land,
a travel review,
Hong Kong by Bill Burr, a bunch of
selfish people eating dumplings. Fuck,
this is based on one guy who was going
to Hong Kong who I don't even know if he
was going there. I forget if he lived
there or if he was even Chinese. Um,
so anyways, how do you watch
this shit all day? MSNBC or you?
You seem like a news junkie.
I'm kind of a news junkie.
I don't watch it intently,
but I,
I like keep an on as wallpaper and
periodically glance over and see like,
oh, shit's hit the fan. Holy Crap.
It's been two hours
since shit's hit the fan.
It's kind of more enjoyable
with like the sound down.
I'm loving this guy on the right.
He has the exact same haircut.
Is a Prince Charles sticks out
the exact same way? Yeah, it does.
Except he's got more hair
on top if that's his hair.
But what I like is that he's completely
covered in the graphic that the stock
market is tanked today. Uh, they,
they do that to people. Like if I,
I have to be on CNN, uh,
and what next week. Okay.
And it's my first time. Oh, nice.
So I'm going to be in one of those
squares and I just hope the stock market
hasn't completely gone to shit and I
get blamed for it because that's what
you'll remember is this
guy caused your stocks.
I don't even know that that
was about the stock market.
I just look at that guy going,
that guy's fucking is made.
That's the haircut of you,
that there's people right now that have
lost their pension because the stock
market's down in,
they're looking at this guy like it's only
down 300 285 bucks though, right? Yeah.
Yeah. I mean that's not what that
is that through an $89? Yeah,
it was like down 500 or something before,
I dunno. 500 bucks. What is 500 banks?
I don't, I don't. I do. And it's
the worst. You can't get out of it.
Usually pay attention to
it. Do you file? I don't.
I just look at it like I'll never get
that money back in whatever's left when
I'm 65 of you. Oh Shit.
I just view it. It's,
it's like Las Vegas without all the
really gaudy like decorating and,
and buffet food. It's just like Las Vegas.
I've done like, I've done okay in it,
but I also,
I invest conservatively and
with conspiracy theories.
So for the blue chip,
I go for like tangible shit,
like people who make tangible shit.
And I'm of,
I invested in all these companies that
were like digging for gold and stuff and
then, cause I felt the
dollar's going to collapse.
But then it dawned on me one day, it's
just like, well wait, at the end of this,
I don't have any gold.
So I bought them a bunch of shovels and
pickaxes to give to children somewhere
to dig us out of the ground. And in the
end, oh, you know what I was talking to?
Who the fuck was I talking to me?
A friend in Chicago that is literally
made millions of fucking dollars.
This is really sick. All right,
but I want you to listen to this.
This is really emblematic
of what's going on today.
Is this place haunted or is that somebody
hammering? No, that's somebody have,
okay, just making sure destruction
zone right now. But this guy,
uh,
would wait for a mass shooting
and as soon as that happened,
he would invest in gunstocks.
And sure enough,
gunstocks would go up,
spike 25 points on the day.
Like he come in there and go 100000 bucks
and just buy whatever gun stock after
a mass shooting within three
days, he would sell it all
before it went back down.
And he's made millions just
doing that now. Right. It's
kind of creepy, but it is.
This is where we're at.
Right,
right. But I'm trying, I wouldn't
try to make it that way. Now.
What way can we do it?
What?
Let's think of another disaster that
happens where we can make some money every
time there's a slide. Do you invest
in what? Well, I don't know about it.
Dryer, so I'm just investing
in part futures, man. Now
that Canada's going legal,
I'm all in. I'm actually going to
join the stock market and uh, uh,
I think a solar and wind and all these
other like new tech things are kind of a
scam.
But I'm,
I'm all into the pot market because we
saw what like alcohol didn't the 20s
after the end of prohibition and uh,
all the mega,
mega giant corporations that came out of
that, like Anheuser Busch and all this,
and I think pot's going
to be the same thing.
It's not going to be a bunch
of mom pops in Marin county.
It's going to be like huge.
Well, do we have a watch science?
Yeah. I mean, have you
watched sewn on that? Uh,
was it vice set the name of the channel
where they did like putting it into food?
I mean it's becoming like this before
may thing overnight. Yeah. I Cook,
I cook part food. Dude. You think
that'll ever happen for like heroin?
Like today we're making
some opiate English muffins.
Why don't you take like two bites in
their urine test? Because they a
poppy seed muffins or so they claim,
Oh, give me a fucking break. That's
what they claim. But I'm just saying,
so there is opiate food's already but
poppy seed muffins after
they shot some heroin,
that's why they fucking failed a test.
Let's say when people talk about,
I used to joke about that when people like
say like, oh, it's, you know, I'm not,
it's my metabolism. That's why
that's, that's the big scapegoat.
I had metabolism, it's
really slow. It's like, yeah,
that and fucking 6,000 calories a
day that will make you artist shape.
Um, so anyways, uh, all right, well let's,
I think we're about to,
this is the most effortless
fucking 58 minutes of my life. Um,
I'm so psyched they
get made another album.
I've heard the one track
twilight zone thing.
I just video out, I saw the
video. I love that. And,
and the new video comes out on March 9th,
two,
not one of these like a concocted
by the label lyric videos,
which we have no part of.
And I,
and I guess they're pretty good and
kids like him and all that, but we,
we don't put in any really input
into that. That's the label.
Just wanting you to get to know the
lyrics and things in the most basic way
because people have the attention
span of a fucking bathroom, that,
and this and that. Right.
This next one is, is a,
we filmed it all on the same day,
this twilight zone video
and then victims of a clown.
So I haven't seen it yet. I should
be able to see in terms of a clown.
Yeah, I should be able to
see it tonight. Actually.
We get some rushers on it and I hope it's
as good as twilight zone because that
one's pretty funny video man.
I'm out there hanging with a, um,
a gray wolf, this, uh,
Indian American guy and Matt [inaudible]
aim American Indian movement and a
pretty high level AME guide to,
and we're out there at campfire
just blown harps and uh,
drinking Iowasca t and uh,
it was, it was great. It was,
tell me about your band. You will mention
some of the guys you got in the, yeah,
we got, we got kind of a pretty
good all star lineup. It's a,
Joey Jordison is playing drums of
this as tour Burton bells helped me.
[inaudible] Jordan from,
from uh,
Jordan's and from us slipping on a burden
bell from fear factory has helped me
on the vocals this time.
And Tony Campos from old static gags and
asked casino and about a billion other
bands.
He's in his on base and then our two usual
guitar players in Korean and sees our
Sodo which are awesome.
John Bechtel,
which has been with us for about eight
years and he comes from killing joke and
the early killing joke days. And
um, and then DJ swamp from Beck.
Uh, this is awesome. This,
when are you going to put your tour dates
up? Cause I, I got to send guys alive.
There are, there are, what's your website
first? Uh, ministry? I don't know.
God calm or some shit.
I don't know.
I'm not the best promo sexual youth.
I'm finding that I'm finding that.
All right. Well but al has a new
album out. It's, it's called ministry.
I look by its somewhere and he has a
website that has the name ministry,
something like that. And he is on tour
somewhere. Those dates are available.
It's like a treasure map. And at the end
you get the pot of gold. Just find it.
It's just white ministry.
And either you'll get put to some Billy
Graham webpage or you'll get put to us,
but I know that somewhere you'll wind up
on our page and you'll figure shit out.
Okay. Well Dude, you're
one of my favorite people.
I always love talking to you and uh,
it's an honor that you wanted to come
onto my podcast to promote your album.
I hope that you wanted to and it
wasn't your label making you do this.
And this has been an uncomfortable, our
people doesn't even know about this. Oh,
okay. This is you, Liz
and me. This is orange.
And then we're just going to
spring it on them and go, fuck you.
So what do you do for me?
Nothing. Cool. We did.
We got this famous guy to come over to us.
How about that?
I have a little notoriety.
I don't know what I'm saying though.
This is not labeled sanctioned. All
right, so last thing. What do you,
what are you Blackhawk's doing?
Barely Watch talky this year in
my Bruins made all these moves.
We bought a couple of guys from off the,
the you go work ranges.
She got winkles from us and I was
fourth line guy for you guys. You guys,
we kind of Nash from Hood. Yeah. Yeah.
You got national, the Rangers. He does.
You're looking good. I mean,
and, and this is good for Boston.
You needed this because, uh, when, when
Claude, Julia and was your coach and Shit,
you guys were Oh, down this shit.
Good. I loved them. I loved them. Yeah.
But it was real bipolar there for awhile.
Well he did lead us to our first
cup in 40 years, so I know,
I know because we had three of them.
My Shit Yo plastic box in there as well.
We tied it up and then you guys fucking,
I know you guys tied it up and then,
then you funny 10. That was
good. Yup. Boy For me anyways,
but uh, yeah, we're, we're tanking
right now. Thank uh, uh, it,
it's time to like get some new
blood. I mean, uh, uh, the, the,
the general manager's Stan Bowman,
here's his first year after the first cop
and he made the rookie mistake of a GM
and just like, oh, well of course Chicago.
I hadn't had a cup in like 40
something years. So everyone's like,
we got to keep this team forever.
And you know,
everyone thinks that they're all junkies
and they're going to look the same 20
years from now. What's the running and
uh, and so he overpaid all these people,
lock them in with no
trade contracts and shit.
And now we're stuck with
all these decaying old guys
that don't do enough heroin.
Seabrook still playing for you guys? Oh
yeah. I think, I mean he, he's out there.
That's the best number in hockey.
Seven. Yeah. And individuals nine,
nine and seven nights ago to any,
any like a single digit one is cool.
But those all got retired cause
all the best guys had them.
So now like the big thing is to have the
double. Yeah, that didn't 77 and 99 88.
Oh that shit. All right, cool. Well thank
you so much for coming on the podcast.
I can't wait to hear the
new album and furthermore,
I can't wait to see you guys live.
If you're doing a full show,
I will come out on a toy drum set we got,
we get the double bass pedal.
We've got March 22nd or so in Anaheim
and March 23rd and Ventura and I'll okay
on drums at one of those shows. If
you, if he can fit it in your schedule,
that'd be awesome. Have
a cigarette, but I don't,
I don't know that I'm going to be able
to pee like my double bass player.
I'm just starting. Oh, we'll give
you an easy song to play. How's that?
We'll give you some and,
and we won't fuck with you too hard.
I promise it's your show, man. I don't
give a shit. You want to fuck with me?
Fuck with me. Just the fact that I'll
get to do it will be awesome. All right.
Thank you so much and everybody thank you
for listening and I'll check in on you
on Thursday. Thanks man. No worries.